in einem Video hier habe ich nebenbei
vom Klimawandel gesprochen und dann auch
noch die Kommentare gelesen mein Fehler
hier ein paar
Perlen ja mindestens so schlimm wie die
Lüge von der runden Erde wacht endlich
auf
99,9% aller wissenschaftlichen Studien
gehen davon aus dass der Klimawandel
Menschen gemacht ist ich habe schon
schlechteren Bewertungen vertraut meine
Dönerbude hat auf Google 62%
Empfehlungen und ich liebe sie an der
Stelle sch Serda ich deine
[Musik]
Augen ja es ist wie mit dem Sterben du
kannst es nicht aufhalten aber du kannst
es beschleunigen je nachdem wie viel
wodko du morgens zum Frühstück trinkst
aber seit Menschen alles anzünden was
sie in die Finger bekommen erhitzt sich
die Erde 40 Mal schneller als
vorher ist mir so doof
Leute